[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'ont vécu nos invités date
si tu perds quand tu es avec moi dôme
plan cette semaine en russie roxane
bruno qui est une auteure compositrice
interprète qui tenait aussi créatrice de
contenus que les vidéos sur youtube un
plumeau ristic
un podcast qu'est ce qui se passait sur
iphone c'est peut-être la magie de noël
qui s'en vient juste pas trop quoi parce
qu on lui ben l'fun on ne parlait de
trop d'affaires que je puisse les
dénommés maintenant mais c'est qui ça on
a aussi notre page pétrole ou est ce qui
en fait pétulante c'est une plate forme
à ce que vous pouvez nous encourager
nous et en nous encourageant vous allez
avoir accès à du contenu exclusif donc
on va faire de nouveau podcast à chaque
mois on va faire des clous est né avec
vous vous allez pouvoir poser vos
questions des invités comme vous et vous
allez pouvoir voir le podcast avec
roxane ont appris une question d'un de
nos patrons pétrone donc si vous voulez
aller voir ça c'est vraiment la
meilleure façon nous encourager pour que
nous on puisse continuer à créer le
contenu que vous aimez le lien de
peinture noire dans la description de la
vidéo allez voir ce souplet sinon bonne
écoute pour la remette après faire de
l'animation
je mets le lien de son site web la vidéo
merci
[Musique]
0-0 on est sans merci
ça fait plaisir ligue 1 quand qu'on va
faire tourner notre intro en a besoin
c'est de mettre un titre ou à nos
invités c'est de mettre un rôle à nous
inviter dans la société
toi c'est difficile c'est la pine est
tellement d'affaires certainement parce
que moi aussi j'ai de la misère à quand
les gens me disent droite comme la
gauche
mais je ne sais pas comment les gens ils
veulent que je décris de ma musique puis
je sais pas quoi dire pas de la pop pas
du rap se pose du jeu c'est bosingwa
mais ces mêmes maux de la musique du
fait de la musique mais tous des vidéos
que sa paroisse de la musique je sais
mais drôle piette toile
c'est comme une belle comme c'est moi
qui pensais de montage non mais ya pas
de montage ce qui coule dans ses
affaires des packs hpst déjà fait des
podcasts en a fait une coupe avec what
the fuck yeah ouais mais je pense mon
deuxième j'ai vraiment un objet de
podcasts les von doom on a découvert une
réelle passion pour ce jeu qu'on parle
des conversations vraiment que tu postes
non mais c'est vrai si nice puis moi
j'aime l'espèce des faits je commence à
enfiler guette pas de john cox genre
c'est moins bon volant loin et plus haut
tout d'un coup je t'aime enchaînement
faut juste attention un petit peu est-ce
que ça va rester comme ça
mario pelchat en reste et se fait passer
du banc trop pas la nuit
je faisais autrement j'ai rien contre
seppi team est on avec l'adisq justement
ils disent avoir un peu plus de monde
[Musique]
vraiment droite dure sopi en plus que
dit le 10 jours dans une entrevue
lendemain dans une radio au saguenay de
façon vraiment pohé jean le goff rocher
jamais le sud qui ont pas assez c'est un
statut qui avait fait genre non ça a
commencé dans une entrevue de même en
jasant poser la question de comment tu
trouves que tu penses et grenat de
l'adisq potro s'est pas question petit
et du sud que dit exactement titre
acquis il trouvait qu'il trouve ça plate
que c'était surtout les artistes plus
marginaux plus tu es de gauche c'est que
le téléthon qui gong la majorité des
prises et mettons klô pelgag ibarra nord
moi je pense que les mérites je pense
que les mérites pitié il dit ses poches
qui avait tant qu'il gagne c'est super
bon aussi factice a mené tout le monde
mérite aussi son enfant mais faites-le
la face et qui est bien évidemment il ya
eu réponse à ceux qui
moi je trouve que la façon qu'il aimait
dieu le rende vraiment pire plus boxer
c'est comme le saint graal
mario pelchat du pilori il faut y mettre
des guillemets déplace que ça va
vraiment pire que ce qui s'est vraiment
pas à ça ça devient une espèce de débat
vraiment trop grand pour ce que le griot
dit abbas et dit son opinion qui plaît
pas certains émeutiers garde les tuyaux
rien dit vraiment de kate à la demande
par la presse a par exemple comme le
j'aimerais ça pouvoir comme jean zay de
symptômes et jusqu'à moi même si je dis
ceci ils vont bien prendre les autres
c'est parce que tu vas aura une fille
qui veut qui comme tu ris ou fâchés de
pouvoir glisser si je dis maintenant
cuba le noir les mérites et ses trophées
mais sa rétine en faisant donner à
d'autres aussi ses mots c'est ma façon
de penser mais en même temps c'est un
peu la façon baby l'a dit que tout le
monde rigole c'est comme le lendemain
comme ça dit les médias
l'espèce de ça vraiment de fellation du
félix le tout le monde parlait que de ça
mon petit parler de la musique
on peut aussi parler de la musique son
petit parler des autres trucs qui ont
été dit pendant la disent qu'il y avait
vraiment de place le courrier d'un homme
réponse à ce que je me plante justement
vos balades dans les bois et des plus
redoutés la licence et sabra sont
tellement entendu moins parler ses
dreads de jeu
la fin du pétrole ifp et rocky petites
mains et se cherche et cherche à nantes
où ça tourne à la changez pas donné à
tous et a pas que le loup y soit à
changer le loup par trudeau même si
c'est bon c'est vrai je suis à la diète
[Rires]
tout un chacun pour 1,5 million de
personnes
c'est maintenant un show quotidien j'ai
pas me planter mais ces cinq simples si
c'est un personnes qui sont le lot de
tout le monde il ya beaucoup aimé ça
pour dire que j'allais tout mario
pelchat à tout moment par la france qui
a dit le sait que jodie et comme bien
doute sur la la façon de faire de la
distance est-ce que genre les volumes
liées comptabilisé parce que c'est
vraiment juste piliers comme peut planer
le doute et des magouilles la dette
c'est comme mario le genre d'action en
parle au camp les injustices côtoient
les invités des fois qu'ils ont rien à
voir ça fait des mélanges improbables
mais c'est vraiment une émission qui me
fait partie un jour j'étais invité labo
il va écouter podcasts les morts non
j'ai pas qu'une pause désertification
petit enfant de choeur
je veux pas me prononcer je sais que
c'est triste le pire informez vous au 6
mai - la politique j'ai de la misère à
comprendre
suivent un jour avoir une opinion
là-dessus ce vraiment moutons pas que le
son commence à parler si j'étais invité
en même temps qu'un ministre de quelque
chose
[Musique]
sarr époque il se met à parler de la
culture mais complètement dans l'opinion
à tous et rock paris pas ouvrir ma
première entrevue radio quand j'ai sorti
mon album ça j'ai sorti mon album à peu
près en même temps quelle espèce de
scandales quel effet ils sont moins
payés dans le domaine les faits sont
toujours moins un pays où sandra mais
dans le domaine de la musique le steak
offre le gros legros stikeman de ce
moment le plus à ma peine comme bonjour
je pense qu'on a entrevu belle victoire
à san bruno
tu penses quoi des gens avec palmes sont
moins payés la musique je ride est moins
vrai que c'est 4 5 ans mon album et son
maillage je peux vraiment pour ce match
est vraiment en train d'être poète pour
s'adonner porte à quoi la 50e place et
si jamais ce que tu vaux d'ici demain ça
sera mon repos et on importe quel site
plus avec 10 formés parce que pour vrai
la ligue email
bah oui c est moi je relis des enfants
qu est ce que j dilla dormagen c'est
trop beau c'est gênant les mêmes les
règles du journalisme sont floues -les
ces mêmes les règles d'éthique en
journalisme c'est flou il ya eu mon âme
et auteur préféré quitter et un
journaliste disait of the rich ricci
existe pour ces gens là non médecin
qu'on se parle de gens est une bonne
chose mais voilà ça s'appelle la
casquette un mois comme un personnage de
final fantasy
alors c'est vrai ou pas de quatre on a
reçu naruto
[Rires]
les amis non mais rappelle les quartiers
guillot un pokémon qui évoque une bonne
série
le stand hall the doors
ouais j'avais tellement de cartes même
encore aujourd'hui c'est ce qui comme le
plus mais ne veut minière s'ils écoutent
pokémon sérieusement encore aux
américains des générations ah oui la
police à 50 millions et 100 millions
d'alice à pokemon co va pas durer
longtemps encore c'est juste que tu as
des amis jouant des noms bon mais ça
fonctionne avec mon chum au centre-ville
encore le justement vont rentrer les
nouvelles générations
ce n'est pas juste avec les sensations
je commence à jouer là bas pascal
pendant trois semaines les rues étaient
pleines
ils partent chez les patients avec un
peu c'est l'université laval il y avait
c'était justement qui se connectent leur
sel dans l'ombre terrebonne en deux
temps du dernier des vêtements des
personnes âgées qu'ils en font tout mais
ça c'est vrai que dd guèye que les
sharks n'ont pas manqué leur seul en
train de game et qu'elle a été allégée
vidéo d'un gosse un japonais s'est fait
faire un vélo du genre rubis de celle
sur son vélo tout sur pokémon dont le
siège est à malte en aucun cas un cas
pokémon des le plus c'est genre si celle
ci comme c'est d'écouter 8 mai pias
façon set up de pokémon gris fixé sur
son vélo ça résonne dans ma tête que je
vois ce genre de truc qui pourrait
vraiment mais non syndiqués j'exagère
tout le temps à la bouffe c'est
rassurant nous amuser les tripes sur le
japon puis genre si c'est vraiment lui
ce qu'ils disent et si tu peux
l'imaginer ça existe à tokyo si tu es
capable d'imaginer la patente le sexe de
ce labo et son épouse afef octobre
suspension des téléréalités et télé
réalité la beauce et culture soit notre
fougue des enfants elle
[Rires]
j'ai demandé à david capital et au japon
de ramener en taille mais en vrai
l'apport des pizzas italiennes place
puis genre y avait plusieurs étages puis
plus tu montes plus d'être hp lui dis
juste arrivé je t'arrête et jaro milieu
puis à la bdic me ramener c'est quand
même encore le ski tentacules des robots
des robots beaucoup de remous non mais
on a pigé dans l'histoire 18 ans il y
avait une loi qui est telle et en
taillant tout d un homme sans ils sont
obligés de faire avec des énormes seins
sinon sinon trop parler des petites
filles pour ce qui est joli une loi qui
fait que jean fauque les sainsois de
tels grosso elle et ses suppôts
passionnant manie la wii
ça serait trompé des omeyyades
long silence non non mais on s'entend
que là là pour nous la baule souvent
c'est exact qui s'est souvent des tipis
ceci s'est passé kiwi d'arghandab une
série d'entrevues avec des pointes store
c'est un gars sur le double appel qu'à
cmj à l'attaqué puis lui fait après
avoir mangé c'est la passion la
sexualité ou jamais pour l'avenir non
mais j'ai deux vu des reportages vice là
dessus que la bo
le monde tout le monde est célibataire
quasiment le monde fait plus en couple
on n'a plus d'intérêt fait en couple
mais il ya des endroits où tu vaux pour
des collégiens
c'est comme si aller voir du côté droit
des prostituées mais tu fais juste connu
pour avoir l'affection et à flatter ce
point sans aller en sentant j'irai pas
coller je trouve ça plus normal en
guimet de pays brûle habens et un
personnel à l'école et c'est impersonnel
ce soir la france la différence est là
parce que la donne soit pas de relation
d'affection team est le tueur recherché
de l'affection nous a vraiment dans une
société où s'est rendu tout est rendu
ultra un personnel aussi ceux qui le mot
culte à moins qu'il ait une théorie ne
font plus d'enfants public des problèmes
de société ultra vieillissante les
camions la moyenne d'or je sais pas
c'est quoi mais c'est faux gamecube puis
meurt pas ce sont les biens les jeunes
femmes asiatiques et ail et envoûtant le
[Rires]
triage non métrage et benfica canada
goose j'ai failli crier meurtrier
non mais j'essaye pour réagir
consciente que c'est ta blonde tu vas
jouer dans sa roue de a à z
puis c'est pour les mauvaises raisons
parce que c'est exactement parce que
c'est une figure littéralement au dessus
de véganisme titre de champion serait
que la cause qu'elle est comme big
anguilles mais je me dis o'keefe a créé
le monde si moi je m'habille comme en
tout poil ils vont me juger
pas de jugement mais peu importe les
noms peu importe la raison mais je
voulais pas que ça prenne
mais ce que je vous disais tantôt c'est
que dans la série d'entrevues de cas
samedi à zaki rock est une actrice porno
japonaise en parle encore
je veux revenir sur ça parce que c'est
populiste c'est vraiment oui c'est
vraiment mais est ce que disait c'est
que au japon le taux de le pourcentage
de jeunes filles qui se fait à toucher
dans le métro est vraiment vraiment
élevé jambes et bizarrement sexuelle
dans le métro à cause qui sont tellement
beaucoup pitt et tout le monde prend ces
troubles mais c'est que c'est quel pays
dont le quai jean la procession il ya
ici mais en thaïlande ce pays que
chercher oui ça arrive ici ou là bas
c'est la ville de montréal étrangement
arrive au dans le palmarès des
destinations pour le tourisme sexuel
grand prix de montréal
l'endroit le plus pervers d'une vague
grand prix les gens ici peau pour le
tourisme sexuel qui frappe mais c'est
qu'il ya plein de place maintenant tu
vois plein de deux salons de massage ou
à l'evreux ec c'est ce volet mettant
king club le tuffeau le pitch peut
réaliser temps mais c'est ça mais
mariage me rappelle c'est jesse qui
regardent les salons de massage la
tchéquie comprend pas pourquoi la
belgique et la magouille
oui mais oui mais oui mais oui c'est sûr
c'est sûr que oui mais en même temps
c'est justement un mettons que tu
décides que mettons que demain matin
le grand prix de montréal qui décide de
mettre la hache laden c'est de l'argent
un sacrement mais encore une fois ça ne
part tient peut-être même personne mais
si ces places le sud est une personne
qui appuient personnes qui ne savent ou
traumatisés longtemps j'ai pensé que je
n'ai qu'une demi chama regarder des
vidéos 6 août est une conspiration comme
au disque et sur youtube
sur internet c'est sans doute ce qui est
vrai depuis depuis 15 minutes
trop d'enfants qui sont arrivés dans les
commentaires si on croit encore aux
reptiles et non écoute je pense pas à ce
point là c'est tellement drôle
c'est tellement
vous commencez en coupe bizarre comme un
running gag c'est là devant l'ordi je
voulais trop et manque à sa peine on
s'habitue c'est pas ça fait ses beaux
cadeaux parce que c'est vrai que son
coût bush dit
mais elle sait qu'après ça surfer sur
facebook elle a quand même fait un post
a dit je suis au courant du vidéo
complètement démente si j'ai osé rapport
[Rires]
oui c'est drôle mais l'appétit bon c'est
mon égard dans le viseur de la bosse on
l'a vu à et non sérieusement à moins
traumatisés si je monte ça ma blonde et
moi ta gueule c'est à 38 ans têtu
conspirationnistes que maintenant
jusqu'à maintenant 90 le nom je pense
que l'on sait jamais arrivé est un fait
se croiser trop beau est-ce que les
pyramides ont été faites par les experts
le nom mme etienne triki en septembre on
peut
ben maintenant la lune on ne sait
vraiment à les salines ben oui oui non
si on n'est pas les seuls à passer de
monde parce que tu es allé traîner à
l'arrière des avions le blanche les
jardins pour contrôler les populations
le sait comme des produits toxiques pour
jouer au cerf-volant à ce que les
enfants qu'on sait pas encore où juste
bouger même somme et en faire une espèce
de calcul des probabilités de ses
médecins qu'elle serait plus plus
probable que
mais ton bep ton cap cet art est plate
qu'est ce qui est plus probable entre il
si tu montes dans cinq ans ayant
commandé des regroupements et des
groupes facebook demande pas la gravité
s'expose ils ne manquent pas sur la fin
mais au square est plate
facebook est un bon d'accord que c'est
quelque chose de québec reconnue du
succès contre une fusée qui pour se
catapulter ajar 400 mètres dans les airs
pour pouvait pour voir observer par lui
même que la terre est plate
mais il ya des gogos qui s'appelait ce
don correspond bien sûr et puis c'est
quoi au début était un sou depuis le ive
tombé puis yoga son parachute année est
tombé d'un vab
oui mais elle est passée à août mais il
y avait réussi à stabiliser parce qu'il
tournait trop vite par une tournée sur
l'humain mais son shoot était fait pour
que si ça se met à tourner pendant une
certaine altitude ya les stabiliser fait
qu en stabilisant et qu'on me revenait à
lui-même plus juste et on parle de 30
afin d'aller à londres pour la première
fois de ma vie je t'ai jamais allé j'ai
fait trois matches avait trop sexy
plaque pour dont j'allais splash les
gens
non on a fait une sortie de famille me
rappelle comme citoyen j'ai avec mes
cousins et mes cousines france son
histoire en fait le tout les jeunes
veulent embarquer la force à part au
super manager paul
alors là j'ai prié savoir la vallée
n'ont pas non plus très peu sur ce et
quand il était plus jeune fallait qu'ils
le fassent avec nous je connais en haute
estime
c'est souvent faut que tu rangers 4 pts
2 si tu peux pas être fait avec comme
nos parents ne se parlent est mon pari
tripes après s'être 6 300 plus que moi
okada facile
non non j'ai perdu 8 à moitié bon et
j'étais rouge à lèvres parce qu on
pourrait essayer d'en fermer mais je
racontais winston sera ma blonde en fait
si ça va déranger que la rencontre
autant mais tu as payé sauf et sur
google ce que je veux dire c'est
documenté
en faisant un show ok on parlait que des
fois les titres numérisés d'informer les
enfants et non on a fait un show qui
saute on fait beaucoup de shows corpo
genton fait de cover fait qu'on joue
mettons le 1erdécembre classer les
parties noël on bouquine walsh s'est
endormi par le parti par se parler d'eux
on a joué pour une gamme unique et plus
goût qui était tout un avantage qui
prenait des photos teen mom puis prépa
des photos de visages à ma blonde me
prenais des photos un peu plus but
[Musique]
brulotte et vous et moi j'ai pas vu ça à
l'équipe des switchs j'ai pas jusqu'à
les pilotes ont joué mais de léon jeune
ahmed les rétros ils entendent à la
tonne huit spectacles de passe et
thunder bay le lego fait ce mamelonet
décide que l'espace à passer à pompe se
sert de ses mains du gain qui a dit
alcool a dit si romain et respectueux
qui traînent faranah il a garé son
chemin gayrussia dépose son sel stager
plus loin pour pas que les gars puissent
l'avenant à prendre pour continuer
chauffer que le sel du gorille la csu
tales toulon puis lui dit comité genre
et il faisait un montage henry il
prenait comme le relais
elle n'était pas en jeu mais non comme
des petites shop courte le chili mais
desjardins chamoun pour aujourd'hui
m chameaux à côté des pilotes
faites le cse finalement fin du show là
la fille venue l'âme il dit qu est venue
plein air d'une sauce elles ont fait que
c'est beau
le la main
afficher ma blonde c'est à l'âme encore
sur le carreau a dit j'ai le goût de
justin repose sur facebook pour dire
genre pas conter ce qui est arrivé mais
juste trouver de quoi le danemark puis
j'avoue les comme juste dire de quoi
pour que pour sentir mieux pile heure
une heure après ma robe a fait la voix
lui condamné effective qu'en mai
ça faisait pas si longtemps si longtemps
affecté était sous le radar avait plus
pileux
une journée ce qui l'attend liana bureau
je me soumets téléviseur journalistes
que la paix et que l'appel à l'eau c'est
un amant de journal de québec
j'ai vu ton post qu'est ce qui t'a
enlevé le petit c'était vraiment à pau
dis-je
je traîne en entrevue le site et comme
bonjour aux gens ce qui t'arrive était
vraiment informés à leur tête le à
raconte l'histoire de ces centres où ce
méfier de la menace journal
une photo de ma blonde qui ont trouvé
chez peau ou kala vraiment force et j'en
attends vraiment tabarnak piste est
comme une chanteuse vol le cellulaire
d'un spectateur en pré spectacle un gros
titre vraiment le trompeur plus les
commentaires sur internet
l'histoire est encore une chanteuse qui
fait juste crié fort chez pina nancy qui
est elle
elle fait juste pour faire parler d'elle
dans la nappe le groupe publie par la
commune siemens ce genre on en saura
juste parler de cette histoire de
téléphone
c'est que ces histoires et clac bananes
en gris mais oui puis non pour soi le
véhicube on s'entend qui ont tous c'est
simple si c'est juste dire aux chinois
mais la classe la crotte qui commente le
journal de montréal et québec c'est la
corde qu'il faut qu'ils enseignent à la
mise en fin de partie musulman
exactement
exactement on y arrivera jeanne non non
tout dois tu dois devait aussi se
couvrir potins je suis tellement
chanceuse et je me considère pas ce que
j'aurais paul le manding pour ceux chez
vous avez reçue safia ici gilles est
actuellement mon chapeau de bons
rapports que soit encore debout à face
au nord c'est pas pour rien ça va être
trash et je veux dire mais je me serais
probablement accroché
jean louis annonce vraiment je peux je
pourrais pas vivre autant de
commentaires négatifs pour des trucs
aussi banal qu'un tee-shirt à la danse
au collège la pression que c'est sûr que
ça fait mal c'est sûr que si tu offres
tu veux passer mais on dresse ailleurs
donné de la force sedif au coffre genre
je vois jean paul ii contre happy
attestant je me force encore moins
qu'avant je mets tout bras ça parce que
je me qualifie je me rends parce que peu
importe la façon la plus appropriée pour
quelque chose j'ai tellement pourtant eu
de commentaires négatifs qui quand
j'étais jeune je dois aussi quand même
quelqu'un qui était apprécié et et
j'aimerais que d'intimidation m'est
jamais rien arrivé de dramatique pour
les messieurs le fait que wicked pagny
je comment il y en a pas de grand bien
de poche de la musique c'est tout
arrêtez de chercher un drame
aujourd'hui les commentaires ne
pleuvrait dessus négatif sans vraiment
travailleurs je pense tout ça est ce qu
ils jaloux non non bon c'est un rappeur
sur facebook laisse un trou dans le fond
le guide est une drôle de chose mais au
moins j accorde trop d'importance à ce
gala mais là je reçois plein une
notification sur facebook si je mens
votre équipe c'est une c'est un montage
de ma photo à la dispute d'un petit
rongeur parce que je dis bonne palette
qui s'appelle ça peut marcher puis a
marqué genre séparés à la naissance plus
comme des doutes qui sont au vert qu'est
ce qu'il est mais il ya aussi plein mais
coco qui sont comme paloma jamais en
envoyer chier les gens pas que la pause
a été retiré dix minutes après mais ça a
été dix minutes que je t'ai gens c'est
ça le fait qu'un parce que le monde qui
font comme un i love my daughters of you
bonjour je vends pas content c'est le
chaland les médias traditionnels
justement celles auxquelles matonge
taloche morceau un pauvre et moi je
regarde [ __ ] les commentaires sur les
vidéos je vous réponds à ceux qui
flashent plutôt pmi une box gc est
devenu imagine que tu peux pas répondre
à tout ça parce que je sais du bus et du
mieux que je peux mais je lis plus qu'au
matin sur mettant la tâche de tasser
mais le cas j'y fais maintenant les
choses rousseau j'ai regardé mais si
regardez ce que monsieur madame tout le
monde parce que là c'est mc alger
internet j'ai regardé ce que monsieur
m'a lentement dans sa loge pour elle est
passée de moi si j'avais pas tes vidéos
sur youtube c'est ce temps god ça s'est
bien passé parce qu'en même temps je ne
fasse à type est un look atypique
j'ai une ballade rock ce faire amande
côté aussi parce qu'un look atypique
en même temps on s'acharne à faire le
guet s'habille en fait des fois on sera
bilingue aux 365 jours
tu veux pas seulement pour provoquer
c'est moins choquant mais qui peine
toujours pas la face n'arrive pas avec
une attitude un kit désir choqué et je
pense si cette attitude là qui va
justement déranger monnaie qui habite en
poste qui regardent le tuer mais je
pense que ça dérange les gens ce qui
barrent fait parce que les gens
voudraient pouvoir faire les gens sont
coincés dans un dans un corps et genre
et ses succès fauchois faut que je sois
politically correct c'est comme ouvrir
mon rôle je trouve des fois lourd parce
que je suis la fille parfaite entre
guillemets dans ce sens où je dis jamais
un monde trop où jean-louis charge
perdre grotte ça c'est bien connu c'est
documenté
si je joue comme je savais ce lycée
quant à lui cinq ans les combles pour
moi cette partie là du bar je l'adresse
hommage ici des grosses banques hors
alice mais un autre écrit jean petit a
tout dit au petit palais de la musique
jean ibba ou la première chose que j'ai
connu des bas j'ai mis sur l'album je
l'écoutais et puis j'ai trouvé ça colle
et semant bon c'est vraiment bon
outre ce vraiment vraiment bon pitié on
parle tellement d'affaires de ce que le
monde est prêt samedi mais on parle paul
sa musique c'est moi je peux pas dire
que je tripe là-dessus ce pas mon genre
de musique moi là-bas ou j'écoute ce
groupe
le rapport apporte ma musique mais moi
j'aime le rap français j'aime j'aime
surtout fac quand j'écoute hubbard le
noir et le saxophone et tout c'est pas
quelque chose qui vient me chercher
nécessairement puis je suis vraiment une
fille de texte
moi je suis rentré de mon fils est pas
si ça c'est pas contre le gommer sa
musique vient pas me chercher
sauf que jeta tabarnak confins juste
parler de steve est un comme à
l'extérieur
parler de sa musique arrêter de parler
qui m'a dit je pense encore alice qui
m'a dit je te donne un show le mois je
lève une des franchises de jeu et oui ça
chôme est une pure une pure rock star ah
oui c'est incroyable sociales' j'étais
enceinte siècle
dimanche vincent tchèque ce que je bouge
pour lui un sens tchèque fait le show
bon j'en ai sorti fait des pirouettes
tokyo et c'est samedi les jeunes je
pensais qu il ya 21 ans je pense que
c'est un message que j'essaie de parler
mais je connais pas personnellement mais
je tousse tousse on ben sidi csaba mois
puis j'étudie que son frère a fait parce
que son grand frère julien kitana de 6
kw à la retraite est un album à l'été
2010 site qui le il a été compris à le
sortir mais le hub r c'est comme ça car
explose et qui ont comme licence à la
glace flamands ont décidé de le sortir
je pense un peu le 5 août taille le soir
le fait on va sortir mais bref
julien c'est drôle en plus parce que au
cégep le fonds a fait un an et demi j'ai
tout en musique le cégep et l'université
puis première des cégeps avec avec lui
je lis un chat son geste est bon parce
que
il me disait mon petit frère le trio
j'aurai 14 ans ava panis est malade
comme common wealth julien p lui après
une telle chose n'est pas continuer ses
études en musique et costumes faire la
musique mais le style de trois ans après
ce comme des 6 es si gentil qui bloque
le christ présent la musique ça
ressemble à des cours d'instruments avec
moi je t'ai un guitare jazz parce que
c'est apple diversité c'est c'est
classique ou jazz dans le fond si dja
c'est comme ces pop mais beaucoup axé
sur le jazz mais qui vont venir ici pour
faire du pop tac des cours d'instruments
fait pratiquer beaucoup tandis qu'un
prof téléco de formation auditive se
sent-on toujours d'accord pied qui s'est
constamment tout est capable face à toi
moi faire un niveau le banc tandis que m
sorti mon prochain single parfait
oui au moins toutes les académies
mais ses deux enfants à l'oreille
absolue de monde qui va t'en fais pas
famille témoin ne peut pas faire c'est
moi j'ai pas l'oreille absolue mais
s'ils me donnent une note john aussi
musicien deuxième journée par l'autre
note le porte à dire c'est que ces
jeunes oreilles relatives à tour et des
affaires mais avec une référence parce
que juste dans le vide dans ma main je
sais plus où mettre ce béton mettons que
j'écoute une toune je sais que la
tournée tant d'eau dès lors les coûteux
je veux écouter plus jeunes un accord de
façade huawei est une formation de chant
autoriés 0 ce qui est arrivé j'ai écrit
des tonnes dans un cahier début je suis
jeune mais si mes enfants des vidéos sur
instagram rien sur youtube sur facebook
tout a commencé sur le sodium wasquehal
application sorti qu'un slogan vidéo
pour m'épauler stories le sait je
faisais des codes j'enquête maquis d'une
perruque après sa faute il l'enlève pour
fois les restes un programme de montage
ce qui était plus technique personnages
de comics appelé lors d'un nul a les
mêmes pompiers et c'est ça je commence à
faire sa pierre grâce à lui je t'ai pas
gagne pas qu elle avait filmé à lui mis
sur sa chaîne légers vul et coach du
tout sur sa chaîne youtube elle y
faisait mais pas du contenu est là mais
terrible de spectacles à la voix cassée
le monde ont capoté
je me sens pas tari fac j'ai mis deux
trous autour du temps voit bien la vidéo
qui te plaît grâce à un pli dans un
garage sait comment ça sonne c'est ça
c'est cela moi c'est les premiers en est
une que je faisais sur les internets
puis [ __ ] au est quelque chose que
c'est pas aussi parce que ce soit la
batterie et jeter ou avec la première
toune ses vacances escale à mon nom et
ma soeur avec impression immunes comme
sur ma chaîne a moins plu si la queue
il ya des gens de l'industrie qui ont
sauté sur mon système de faire un album
on parle de quelle année le fait deux ça
fait deux ans que j'ai commencé à mettre
des données a lonely tunes peut-être
quatre heures que pas traîner le thread
départ on m'a sauté pour l'humour ouais
puis après ça ils y ont vu mon contenus
musicaux puis on va faire un blend et
deux de ces lieux que les dix quartiers
qui ont fait étudier l'offre en cd j'ai
dit non et on dit ben oui j'ai dit ok
j'ai fait a cédé pour vrai et j'ai
aucune formation genre encore la seule
afin que fait que ça a vraiment marché
je pense que c'est mon côté un peu
marketing sur internet
mais si t'as pas besoin la plupart des
artistes le conte conique fonctionne le
suspens du monde qui ont fait un bac à
musique le jeu je suis moins content
quoi du piquet qui ont masqué découdre
mais tu t'entoures de monsanto des
réalisateurs qui ont le programme petit
toad
mais c'est vrai que la plupart des gens
qui qui est créé utiles les auteurs
compositeurs y en a pas beaucoup qui ont
fait un parcours académique
les musiciens que je plisse les yeux qui
guide qui va avec
il faisait beaucoup de projets mais
comme second est accompagnée d'autres
réalisateurs
le séjour de go il faisait beaucoup de
corpeau aussi enfin encore d'ailleurs
mis personne ne reconnaissais ces gens
c'est qui c'est quoi ton nom on se fait
six fois qu'on se fout il me soutient
baume à face pis mouche au so cute parce
qu'elle a maintenant été nominé puis
tout ces trucs là l'album ça marche mais
maintenant les gens ils sont là même son
nom c'est toute l'âme et rythme revient
à moins au bout de la ligne mais j'en
pense c'est donc je pense que je fais
tout seul jahia du monde qui ont pris
des photos mais un guitariste sa
génération et de juillet
[Rires]
ça a donné ce nom c'est trop grosse à
mes musiciens ont beaucoup à voir là
dedans il y apporte tout le reste des
sièges patients non pelucheux pas comme
j'ai la science infuse
c'est simple c'est doux - ont fait des
vents studio puis à qui vous pensez que
ça pourrait être quoi l'on l'improviste
quand tu t'entoures bien faut pas que tu
as peur de de respecter l'opinion du
montrées hésitantes aussi choisi pour
cela m'a délégué aussi parce que tu es
quand ça fait dix ans que tu entends de
chansons tout envoi ajoutait plein
d'instruments par dessus tu m'as tout
reste encore dans l'album est encore
proche du qui t'envoient pareil mais ça
ne veut pas dire que j'aime pas mon
album et on l'a quand même garou schiste
album nous on avait pu le budget
pourtant pas que ça a été comme c'est
pour ça que tout les toons qui passe à
la radio les comme les gens sont comme
pourquoi tu le changer parce que ça
passe à la radio 6 tel quel faut pas que
nous on aime mieux les liens visite tout
cas je veux sa part sa radio j réviser
tous fait leur plus produire que ça dans
mes chansons sur l'album secure à la
radio ça passe moi non ou s'ils vont
peser c'est bon tu fais dans le fond
c'est parfait on parle est en tout cas
les gens sont mis à triper khatami
t'étonne ce sur youtube des tonnes qui
ronge hard 2 3 millions de vies ou 6
octobre
ouais je sais c'est faux quand et
comment extrader 3 millions de news
et georges bombarde posé je vous des
artistes qui sortent un single de
plancton l'huile sur instagram singles
pendant un mois au niveau à lyon 10000
views 15 me dis aux gens tout été conclu
c'est vraiment la stratégie je pense le
tchèque je t'aime en compte même pas 10
parce que c'est bon de contrôle des
comptes et met le monde on dit chez rita
titoni nasa j'ai dit oui je pense je
pense pas une semaine dans ma vie où je
n'entends pas mon cd dans le champ de
quelqu'un sur la route
l'autre jour statham andros un vieux
monsieur écouter mathonnat radio gens
étaient moins bien chanter le monstre à
côté de ma langue je fais en sort et m'a
demandé comme c'est ce que ces mêmes
boutiques la première fois je
t'attendais à radio j'avais aucune des
deux équipes non c'est ça c'est ce qui
arrive la phase vient peau avec la voix
zac peau parfaite en fait charité qui
met souvent s'est apaisée méchant
méchant je peux je faisais juste pour le
lien entre les deux ouais c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'ils aient un gérant comprennent
artistes qui commencera comme le monde
savent comme à face avec en tout il
avança attendant face à moi non plus
bonne chance
c'est long c'est long mais c'est un long
travail puis surtout quand tu penses pas
par les grosses machines
ben c'est sa force c'est ce que moi
j'allais dire dans ton cas toi secteur
comme tout comme percer un peu de pub le
chant traditionnel en passant par un
média alternatif le tue j'aimerais ça
dit il c'est en autodidacte qui tout
mais ça va chier c'est josé g j'ai rien
contre les gens qui font la voix même
que je regarde tellement les couilles à
dire non devant 1.5 million de personnes
encore le s'étoffe l'heure on s'entend
puis je sais pas si ma voix passerait
devant vous et moi je pense que c'est
une combinaison de touches en ma
personne le look est ce que j'offre sur
internet des gens le fait que choix 100%
vrai que ça fonctionne juste ma voix le
chp une grande grande chanteuse à la
grosse voile je fais pas dire
[Musique]
mais a atteint la voyais quand même
une belle diversité de ses côtes j'ai
qu'un fond trop aux cheveux longs
tellement à faire je peux même pas dit
qu'ils pensaient l'autre aux césars dont
j'adore cette année j'ai adoré ce mais
on s'est attaché à votre saison beaucoup
plus que je me suis attaché à cette
saison parce que comme comme je t'ai dit
autrefois vous vous êtes là les lots en
sachant peau du tout qu'est ce qui
allait se passer
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de
personnes qui ont participé cette année
c'est vraiment rien contre vous le voyez
ça j'ai confiance dès 2000 mais il
savait ce qui allait se passer un gros
following ce qu'il faut pour se saisir
savait pas c'est ça c'est exactement
maisons sont allé le retrouver mais
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est acheter
trouve plus tard est plutôt un fait si
le même principe que la voie puis là
quand est ce que tu dis plus tu en fais
moins le public s'attache aux gens c'est
a fallu qu'ils arrêtent star académie
voilà c'est fait deux saisons que je
sens que ça commence étirer la sauce mme
lafont le seul à l'école des couteaux
des saintes maries ouais mais que des
couteaux grand descendu depuis une
couple d'années à changer de produit à
voir ses productions j le cpie
productions j puis j'ai soufflé
discrétion pas bon je regarde les êtres
humains qui va enlever puis je me dis
harri olli rehn les habitants gardent
ainsi que les commandants sont tellement
ridicules tout le monde est la plus
belle fois que j'ai jamais entendu c'est
quoi
simon flatter les 17 ans justin mapp en
pleine face au monde ses chaussettes et
speed the run est bonne mais genre
acquis à la 60 ravailler paraître les
genres médias qui a été la plus belle
voix le séjour complet gaulle jusqu'à
fin contre soit finie apprécié cette
débrouille tout seul c'est la fin quand
tu es dedans depuis crois qu'un candidat
et tout va trop loin [ __ ] est vraiment
tu crois c'est pile 4frags honte que
s'est passé samedi se tenait deux
minutes le vrai c'est l'as gens moi je
pensais que tout le monde avec mon
parcours quand je rencontre des gens qui
me disaient ça fait mouche anime une
soirée révélations à plat des as puis je
présentais des gens qui venaient faire
leurs chansons leurs compositions bien
coulissé nous et comment tu fais jamais
trop comment tu fais tes ou même où ça
fait 15 ans je fais ça oui je l'anem la
souris ce fait si mon album est sorti
ses sous non merci j'ai gelé vraiment eu
facile la vie d'un bébé gorille de tulle
est au dessus un peu le symbole
important c'est d'être lâchement dans le
milieu vraiment depuis la diski je
dirais que ça l'a descendu un peu moins
mais avant l'a dit ce que j'avais pas ma
place nulle part jean j'avais
l'impression que je faisais de la merde
les jantes et comcast aussitôt qui se
fait du contenu à pic après c'est
quelque chose que tous les influenceurs
guillemets vivre au soleil ou barbie
fait quelque chose en vrai que c'est
moins reconnue vous en doutiez damas à
cesser ces gens le font malheureusement
regarder de haut
mais comme ce n'était pas travail h
désole le ménage tout seul on est une
prod titi travail c'est tout qui botte
le cul matin puis mes mots je trouve ça
beau parce que tu es la preuve que tout
le monde pense qu'à musique des fois
c'est tout à faire des plugs puisque la
sphère des tirs toute la preuve que
c'est pas cette affaire l'autre la
reconnaissance 0 personnes dans les
districts amusé
aujourd'hui chadema pressant besoin il
fallut sourit cette personne leur tête
ont troqué ce point n'a pas d'industrie
beat plug ins en enfer des jeunes
l'escale monde toutes des femmes c'est
tout le monde qui aime ce que tu fais
piste ce que tu fais petit monde qui
aime subsistent sur les réseaux ben ali
puis du monde faut s'entourer de toi tu
souffles au travail toi ci dessous si un
couteau à double tranchant quai du
mont-blanc s'entourer mais aussi des
gens qui veulent tirer à côté irakien
je rentrais pas là-dedans nécessairement
mais j'ai fait des mauvais move au début
de ma carrière je paie le prix
aujourd'hui sa voix mêlée pour les
belles promesses le jeu de mes belles
promesses le monde a vécu c'est le seul
joueur des kings il indiqué non mais non
mais de faire ce dont on l'a vécu aussi
après au décès en haut comme en bas on a
ledge est perdu quatre mois qu'on aurait
pu utiliser pour aller de l'avant le ts
faire durant mais il ya ceux qui s'en
vient peut-être que ça va arriver pierre
web je te rapelle une prochaine mais moi
c'est cela on peut être moi j'ai
vraiment des questions pour sam facile
de tourner non mais le après od me
fascine vous avez des jobs avant de
rentrer là vous êtes parti pendant des
mois vous revenez comme moi je vous jure
la chance d'avoir ne pas vraiment avoir
le job de bureau maintenant le team
j'écrivais pour une maison d'édition
puis j'écrivais à à contrôler le tiff et
s'était jeté pigiste l'enfant le plus
âgé que j'ai recommencé à faire sans
certains dirigeants fait un ou deux
contre eux puis timo j'étais chanceux de
faire ça mais c'est pas tout le monde
que cette chance le téléthon je pense à
hello le qui était préposé aux
bénéficiaires si je vous ai proposé des
initiations job à temps plein
pierre alors décidé de faire ce de
laisser sa job de faire ce pilote sort
de l'opi quais des villages ans après
qui s'occupe de vous voilà nous on était
à cannes agents orpi lui s'occupe celle
ci
c'est dur de dire qu'est ce qu'on fait
les vrais maintien on crée du contenu on
fait de la pub c'est ça mon père comme
ça tu vois puissance parce que toi tu as
été à l'adisq moi c'est venu avec le
livre maintenant quand on a sorti un
livre de recettes là c'est là qu'elle
m'en fais ok ce qui sort il fait rouler
partout votre livre je sais pas si on
est partout bas et malaxer ça je pense
que ça a fait que le fond c'est plus
facile de comprendre que ce fait mis à
beaucoup de monde qui ont un fait après
nous pratiquement rien puisque le je
sais pas qu'est ce qui fait qu'au delà
d'avoir bien fait peut-être aussi aux
affamés qui nous était que je suis aussi
surpris jobs
john normale sur prends ta vie normale
c'est ce qu'écrit complexe puisqu'il est
difficile pour les gossip accepté de
faire ce mois maintenant de me dire
qu'il juste pour payer les bills mettons
je vais aller travailler dans un bon
resto mettons le challenge a à me dire
comment morgan j'aurai la menace qu'elle
me voit le raf le ramenait des aciers
data mais tu en es tu sais ma phobie
parce que moi à l'école je fais
longtemps parce que justement ça
marchait pas au dessus un déficit
d'attention
ouais puis je te dirai oui j ai encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle est connu
pour faits pour tout le monde ces gens
une façon d'enseigner avec un individu
parce que pour moi
pour moi ça fonctionnait pas du tout un
paquet j'ai quitté très tôt selon leur
projet lanchettes j'ai essayé de
retourner à dieu ça peut marcher la
porte ne peut pas développer le bim sa
marche mes enfants je peux très bien
vivre gens vraiment même mieux que quand
je travaille 40 heures semaine but mais
demain matin sa part été et ce qui était
pas un
oui je fais quoi demain matin sans ride
pauvres et elle que je vous retourner
travailler dans un épisode des posters à
6 mais c'est que ça amène aussi un
espèce de l'espèce de pression bizarre
parce que tu dis admettons sallanches je
sais que je pourrai pas faire ce
puis a retourné quand même étant juste
pour par orgueil part parce que c'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne par
contre tu dis si sa large si j'ai plus
rien conseil business place de l'argent
l'anif imagine parce que c'est difficile
pour tout les créateurs de contenu team
est on
je regarde je regarde james ltée james
et lui ça marche à fond on lance moment
sourit travail un travail en inas en
effet quatre vidéos par semaine c'est on
entend les autrefois on l'entendait
groupe et ses sens c'est fou qu'est ce
qui fait sauf que c'est pas deux
semaines choix du montage une même vidéo
moustache tombe en vacances puis en bas
on entre dans mon corps a lâché
complètement les jeter un oeil milan
tourne et c'est comme des premières fois
là j'avais jamais pris l'avion on prend
l'avion va faire des choix mais juste
pas les choses extrêmes avec ton
matériel tout le monde vont s'aimer
c'est bon c'est bon comme en vacances je
tombe malade sinusite puis tout le kit
inspection de voitures quand encore il
dit à wright pour ça suffit ac j'ai
pensé comme tu encore le jeu fait le
montage même vidéo c'est comme si je
tombais dans le bar team on peut même
pas se permettre ce dangereux mais toi
c'est toi c'est que tu es sorti de ce
média lotis sauf qu'il ya beaucoup m'ont
qui sont juste dans ce média lopy ne
sais pas comment il est à la merci un
petit peu dit médian en même temps si on
en parle avec pl le pen qui dit
maintenant youtube y pousse youtube
rugby posséder des grenouilles original
mais original you tube 80 s qui vont ont
besoin de youtube a encore prédit crise
comment tu sors de tout commentaire tout
pitt y mettons à l'oeil du public
l'adisq c'est quand un peu l'air
tamestit dans vraiment le logement
étudiant qui m'ont suivi encore
l'impression de littéralement ils m'ont
mis au monde
c'est fou je pense que c'est ça qui fait
que mon lien avec eux et si fort c'est
qu'ils m'ont littéralement donné cette
chance le tac aux immigrants m'amuse qui
es tu pour ce peut-être que ça
fonctionne un poc ça fonctionne moins
maintenant quand ça fait douze la voie
que tu vois ben christine de pointe aux
trembles si elle va faire la voix mais
les gens n'ont pas l'impression d'avoir
un lien avec un petit mouton
si cette époque parce qu'on le connaît
personnellement c'est qu'il derniers
gorilles en sport academy mais ni alcool
et académie navale connais
personnellement c'est jean-marc sourire
mais j'entends qu'on s'en suit c'est qui
mais si je pouvais même pas fait academy
dans la baie du mont ham et andréanne en
malherbe qui suivent le 2700 je fais
plein de trucs avec un champ d'action
ouais change l'issue veulent pas
longtemps ce qu'avait fait son chemin
comme moins de monde que ça marche
sa ligne
je pense que le monde que ça marche ça
aurait marché et neo est la voie ferrée
marché différemment pas même vitesse
métier le ça marche parce que le mont
terme polis parce que c'est ce que tu
fais c'est bon c'est tout en se quittant
un lien que tu es fan comme ceux des
saucisses part importante est ce que
tout ce qui était juste
une personne
beige sans personnalité ou te où les
fans ont un lien vraiment émotif avec
toi tu es très contentes qu'elles
aillent lentement mais sûrement
c'est souvent quand ça fait tant ouais
tu vois ça c'est pour pourrait rebondir
sur ce que tu parlais tantôt
d'occupation double team et ont tout
fait propulser quand following qui est
énorme et spaulding l'oeil de soutien ne
suis pas pour la personne que tu es
moins et puis parce que ils t'ont vu
d'une certaine façon
puis parce que pendant un été haut en
sortant de l'eau lequel on y discutait
pas mal là dedans je dise on crée
exactement sauf que après si tu mets ton
quelqu'un à abonnés égal même temps
quelqu'un qui crée son fond de 1 à
chaque jour depuis cinq ans que le monde
le suivent de plus en plus en sachant
exactement c'est qui cette personne-là
lui sont following doit être beaucoup
plus réceptifs que fait on se fait
garraud celle avec le travail c'est
qu'ils ont eux même qui suis vraiment
artémis a pris exactement
mais comment ce toit puis jesse
choisirait cueillons montre exact j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont montré gpo je me
suis pas sentie berne et non maintenant
à l'année je sais qu'à pas resté
longtemps mais moi j'avais cru voir une
fille un peu ça c'est très introverti
mais non avenant adèle si je me suis pas
sentie bernie parce que est flanquée au
beau fixe et nice mais je pourrais je
n'aimerais pas non mais un an je me suis
abonnée parce que c'est comme à moustey
ça je les vois finalement au fesman
faits sont là rhodia qui quittent ou et
5 en val d'azun
mais imputer ceci c'est qu'une fois une
faute sur de l'ôter c'est de leur parti
non mais j'avoue pour faire suite à ce
que tu disais que ça doit être stressant
d'être à la merci de yoto où je suis je
suis je me dis ça comme un pitch est de
l'inde rompt une chaîne youtube cpie
même même pour le podcast y ont placé à
100 cloud scène c'est ce conflit qui
c'est comme ça arrive un paiement une
fois place après ce séjour afin qu'ils
soient transférés à terra fort plus tard
une lettre pour que tu marques seul un
cas de pigeons je me rappelle même pas
comment j'ai fait la monnaie comment je
peux motive mais je sais pour fêter
recherche me rappelle vraiment assure un
pigeon qui t'amène les retards et
qu'importe
c'est certain pima jean de pange aux
autres mais moi aussi je loge tout
musique spectacle publicité que je fait
très rarement un peu vive un peu mieux
que je vivais 40 ans honneur avec
youtube avec maintenant si cette hausse
est que la manne et de la faune à suivre
cette affaire des protons mais si ces
consciences et pour ceux consentis de
mon emploi pour lequel cette connerie
c'est des trucs connaissent et savent
aussi dénoncée moi j'ai les rares fois
où j'ai fait des add parce que souvent
je refuse je dis potable mais les rouges
les fêtes j'ai tout le temps du monde
n'est pas capable d'être influence
argent à regarder je peux pas face c'est
pas très étonnant même si j'ai déjà pas
l'avantagé gbr/roxy maubeuge post vous
avez déjà seul je fais déjà été
commandité par un concessionnaire
oui oui c'est ça puis j'ai décidé de
twister sera place de forage ans j'étais
commencé à regarder se regardent et
samut ma blonde on se filme dans le
chambre jusqu'à une journée
by normalement c'est mon jeu steam puis
j'en sais qu'avec ma blonde juste hors
caméra ces quartiers pauvres comme ce
tableau non non et ça donne du bon qu'on
n'utilise et aguila le concessionnaire
puis ben content parce que ça pense pas
comme ça mais pour ce qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui sait plus si naturel
plus le monde ouvre l'autre avec toi
aussi le thé les personnes qui veut
justement juste un placement streda
petit nom n'est plus là je pense pas il
ya tellement de choix est tellement
personnes qui peuvent le faire oui
déplacement comme les placements de
gourdan aux déplacements non mais là oui
je suis si on a été celle de dimanche le
genre lui comme c'est juste des aides en
cinq minutes de haut débit sur deux a
dit m
c'est ça qui me disent 50 ans à l'air
maintenant l'appeler pour une pub
l'effectuer les 15 secondes de pub pour
des cobayes random quand tu enlèves sûr
quand tu enlèves aussi les peuples que
c'est jay kiev cam qui innovent
quand on allait au fitness les
publicités de taille quand tu enlèves
après ce bâton après la pause avant la
semil de bonneville pour les missions et
les avants puis après la pause je me
suis rendu compte au début j'ai ce qui
paie mais ce qu'on faisait partie de
l'expérience parce qu'elle est après la
pause sont tellement trompeurs par pu
les écouter ou à une femme ma propre
histoire le comme le mariage d'olive
plaisir mais ce n'est pas vrai mariage
de raison qui nous prennent vraiment
pour des tarifs c'est fini ça finit que
tu peux devenir qui doit éliminer parce
que c'est lui qui font pas à croire que
la personne ne faut pas croire tout ce
qu'ils ont
[Musique]
un état n'y avait pas de chaussées de
bottines plates en tabarnak
j'ai gagné la sympathie va la france
donne au début c'était vraiment les
salles mais le fallait j'ai les meures
nous j'adore de cam ward qui croisent et
c'est vrai un shoot shoot to thrill
connaissait deux candidats faisant djs
kg ce que j'ai rencontré dans un
tournage avec le faudrait et ils l'ont
vraiment à part je les ai vus à ne
jamais parler de ce qu il allie toutes
les mamans qui a disputé tellement
nerveux vous écoute à m'engager sur
plein de trucs justement la seule fille
pour qui j'ai fait du placement de
produit c'est pour deux avec des
applications tout c'est parce qu'il est
en approche l'iphone qui l'a redit de
carte blanche que tu fasses autres comme
nous le permet sinon marilyn c'est le
rival en semaine elle aussi s'est passé
le personnage est tellement fine est
tellement jovial on off the boys à part
je la regardais cheikh omar ait trahi de
pleurer honnêtement a dû pleurer une
demie-heure de vue la scène casque rouge
dans son livre c'est cette fois jusqu'à
fait une crise de panique l'isf et iris
une semaine ouais suremain métis tout
savoir comment faire quand même parce
que c'est faux que je pourrais pas je
pourrai pas être autant avec le même
monde dans une maison et j'ai vu tous
les équipes font même pas voir un
playstation pour rien il faut qu'on
change sd sera officiellement toutes les
filles ont été bonnes ce temps déjà mais
les côtés dégueuler fillon qui a gardé
moralité soude et y apportent non mais
c'est quoi si c'est moi je trouvais ça
parce que là je parle pas dire c'est moi
j'écoute ça pour ça on écoute pour la
mare littéralement son manque d'action
se trouve incroyable mais sa main il n'y
avait pas de biff y avait jean déclic
bec de bichkek en me levant j'ai
honnêtement je de la discute l écouter
j'aurais sûrement même pas mais je n'ai
même pas écouté mon année sûrement
nettement notre dame âgée mais certains
bambins possiblement peut-être que parce
que moi j'ai trouvé ça très strictes et
ce que mon cher ami tallinn estime
philippe aubin me sentais pas bien
j'écoutais ce j'avais si j'avais hâte de
l'écouter ce que je les brosse cas
laisse passer mais ça faisait pas sentir
bien que sérieux pourtant c'est pas
genre on l'a hissé pas bon mais on le
sait n'ont laissé programme en poupe
mais je voyais qui est chiant comme
autant parce que tu sais bien parti non
mais tu apparaissait aussi qui est
amendé tt et fusils tanné d'être sa part
à 6 tours et surtout qui s'il y avait
plus de personnages toxiques à sanaa
toxic l'an passé une senteur pimousse à
me peser chemin des canaux qui te
détacher complètement petit connais
personne le stade je connaissais au lit
que je t'ai émotivement et puis non
n'ont ils pas comme ça le club connaît
l'amour avec moi je dis que je connais
ces deux gars qui faisait figure hainaut
hippie qui fait dit oui ça m'a pris mais
en fait c'est un gars qui je pense qu'il
est
excusez moi l'effet j'espère je monte
pas de respect
[ __ ] l'amour avec toi ta maman avec
toi mais à ce qu'il dégage pour
l'insécurité comme comme l'émission
vraiment paul tango qui au contrôle il
se met en place et le gars qui est drôle
c'est que qui c'est facile de virer
parano dans une affaire de moeurs qui
touche jusqu'à ta face est passée est
restée sans arrêt depuis le dire mon
gars s'ils allaient franchir à nouveau
les jets hands off c'est chez elle mais
lost est vraiment comme une empathie
mettons ne pas faire rentrer cendres et
dans l'émission parce que là ce qu'ils
ont sur finn semaine surprise qu'à la
n'y est pas allé non même table à moins
de rester cool fm propose des
scénaristes qui a 22 ans et que ça
devienne le chemin qui le feront ils
feront sûrement appel à une prochaine je
pense qu'ils ont eu le message clair que
ça l'a justement fuchs caennaise cela un
clic pour aller le sait c'est que le
monde
les pressions qui s'adonnent non mais
j'en ai vus comme des enfants justement
de drame ou de son facebook quand je
regarde mon excellent [ __ ] fujitsu ten
juste pour qu'on sache que c'est
français c'est vraiment le diamant
tarasy aussi qu'elle s'achète bourque
faisait partie de l'équipe du pr - je
suis pas trop foot m'avaient dit que lui
était pas mal de ce que je dis c'est lui
qui a pris la place en fait de gabriel
d'almeida la relève qui lui était sa
propre pile c'est lui qui amenait
vraiment les idées progressistes l'année
passée le taux selic et pousser beaucoup
pour que j'ai c'est en rentrant sexuelle
assumé il voulait faire rentrer des
bisexuels aussi dans patente
il voulait il voulait chez qui un petit
peu tout sauf nécessité souvent étaient
bloqués un peu en instance plus haute
mais lui le site
cette année ils pouvaient pas qui
travaille sur le prochain film de chez
soi c'est lui a quand même pris cette
opportunité la place doit sa bonne amie
examine trois mois six mois la bande à
mon frère avait rencontré à l'hélice est
allé à ckoi bien le festival
outre charles nom le festival de films
d'amener de la can à la rencontre à
tapis rouge vraiment que ça va être
après parce qu'on sentait qu'on a vu
votre vague avoué je sais pas je sais
pas que ça mais je pense s'arrête j'ai
envie de dire il y en a beaucoup
alors pas beaucoup qui vont faire ça
parce que ce qui se passe et qui sont le
lion nous on n'avait pas de contrat avec
les produits
je tente avec produits pour 3 1 puis la
première en dix points décote sur la
première année se prennent 40 % de tout
ce qu'ils font et free vous à 40% et on
le sait c'est du cash un sacrement
c'est puis le maître fédérer sauter sont
des sources serait à 5 40 % de tout ce
qu'ils font comme way pied aux 6m temps
et met donc que toi tu veux donner des
vaches elle même temps que moi je
t'appelle jeudi et s'est tendu de venir
te faire faire une journée au spa avec
un massage qui vaut 75 kg à ce plateau
d' idiots qui met en échange d'un
échange de produits occupait le 40 % la
valeur du produit qui tue et changer de
ta poche
à productions j c'est leur affaire
d'argent n'en maîtrise pas grand chose
parce que le nord mais si tu te donner
un massage 215 pias 40% de la valeur de
ta poche à toi oui mais à brody par
exemple mais ce
ces produits font les démarches qu'ils
trouvent des sites contre incroyable et
elle est cool s'ils font rien puisque
d'un côté tu demandes à produits qui
vont vraiment travailler des produits
laisse plus gros comme c'est elle c'est
une équipe que je sais pas quel point
mais c'est de l'argent qui risque pour
ce week end face à seul
mais beaucoup il reste à l'artiste là
bas alors c'est un vendeur de contenus
à jean kipré 40% c'est démesuré je pense
sur trois ans a décliné à chaque année
genre c'est comme 40 % 30 % des pensions
que tout comme seuls trois ans ta vie
comme dans le tas et l'ailé les
contrôles star academy 7 5 en 50 fois
rien tu peux rien faire tu étais
paniquée aux autres la voie au moins
dans l'émission fini comme un gant à
winamax comme si tu gardes le tt d'un
contrat de 10 ans après c'est exactement
à ce mes mais non c'est semer
c'est triste je fais tout j'ai réfléchi
j'ai pendant le chalet me bâtir une
équipe plus le bois mais sinon je
faisais mes vidéos clips tout seul j'ai
engagé le monde ce n'est pas l'apport
bouquet c'est cool d'avoir une équipe
qui quand il a choisi premièrement appui
que sa clique qui fêtent leur fait
confiance puisqu'il se dit qu'ils vont
faire ça va refléter les victoires et
huit aux actes est vraiment et un en
concordance mais une équipe de demande
pas une décision que ne ressemble plus à
rien de pire que sous toit la liberté
d'expression je m'agite pas pathé
liberté d'expression et à l'écrit mais
ta liberté d'expression créative je me
lançais c'est la chose principale pour
toi oui j'en le faux faut justement là
mon troisième single de chris les se
sont toutes assiette mot calmement du
monde ibo faudrait petit 10 crise la
mouche comme tabarnak
parce que ses seules intentions de la
loi ça fait mal
le mode permettra place qui voit tout
aussi percutant gymnastique pas d'égal
on peut tout le monde s'active pour
faire basculer juin binger pas décidé
encore mais je me suis assez que moi
même je me suis dit je veux en vivre le
plus longtemps possible et radio en les
artistes disparus d'habitude mais moi je
vais encore les radios m'ont tellement
aidés et ckoi m'a poussé comme ça pas de
sens mon invité à 2 c koi paluzza même
chose pour energy team rll toutefois que
je me dis réseau qui roule
cela n'est 2 qui roule dans le temps
passe moins peut pas condamner le seul à
même pas je vais essayer de trouver
quelque chose qui remplace la crise mais
qui penche aussi s'imaginent que c'est
quoi la phrase au complet
le brand dépourvu le sait que oui à un
peu c'est ça mon frère christophe
foot on regarde pas pareil non ça tangue
un sac temps qu'un c'est ça qui est
excitant qu'un parent c'est aussi un peu
mais c'est serov moi c'est ça moi je
mets des sacs à linge est en train de
travailler mon ma maîtrise puis falloir
que je me pose là parce que moi qui suis
je mets désactivé dans mac os la troupe
s'est pas tenue sont six fois plus chez
eux ou aller chercher des méduses mais
l'hypothénuse je trouve ça important
puis je trouve que c'est le langage
québécois étaient développés avec des
sacs qui moi je fais un effort conscient
au quotidien de garder des sacs dans ma
parole dames on parlait en fait
c'est pas je le fais pas dans le sens
mon effort conscient je le fais pas dans
ce sens qu'est l'homme sacrement cette
france lui même on est forcé de dire
remplace pas le sac qui s'en venait non
c'est laid cela les inquiète c'est cela
mon écriture au sipi fred pellerin il
faisait défaut il ya des crises de
tabarnak qui veulent dire plus que
n'importe quoi s'est illustré fait
sortir pourquoi tu que tu gardes des
sacs dans tes comptes et même que la
france 20-18 parce que ça fait partie
nous autres un creuset tabarnak ça veut
pas dire un autre cas notamment active
et puis ceux ci une des forces du
langage que nous on opine - juin un
activiste pour le droit des sacs puis tu
vois danser dans la situation à kehl t
c'est exactement ce que moi j'ai
justement j'ai été élevé à coup de
grisou gardant un sacré bon voilà elle
me rappelle le dr à l'échappée quelque
chose en cuisine tout est un qui risque
de tabarnak de saint sacrement salle de
steed patente à gosses magie du coc a
laissé jean était super bonne moussa
m'énerve quand j'entends du monde sacré
mais pas bien comme des sacs s'enchaîne
mal mobilisa tabarnak c'est beau
tabarnak de corps les soucis mais bien
par un quand les cesti encore laissé
c'est moins sympa au bout de la journée
tout ces gens là qui sont comme non pas
deux sacres à la radio où on venait me
voir me dire la religion est très
présente dans ma vie - pour moi le
tabarnak s'est-elle telle chose dans
l'église un calice et elle te colle pas
facile du sol mais je peux je peux
comprendre mais il ya un homme ça va
choquer dans leur voiture par un accent
j'entends parler exact
nos amis secondaire qui dicte pas leurs
cinq premiers matches il parlait un
mauvais français non un autre juge noël
avec un show biz et qu'il s'exprimait
mardi par les un mauvais français
on use de benoît je me bats comme arme à
11 et bal avec lui et c'est bien
s'exprimer le sait pas de parler sans
mal français en national
si ce kit est ce que tu es bien capable
de communiquer tapas et est ce que ton
engagé coloris et ce qu'ils vivent et
évocateur sculpter une histoire dans
matin je trouve que tu exprimes gardois
s'élève sur yvan les émotions c'est
souvient s'exprime un robot ces peaux
utilisées là la bonne
pourtant aucune erreur dhafra site et
grammaticales s'est passé bien
s'exprimer c'est formulé sa pensée une
passerelle si je vais le soulever non
ces sorties émotions si j'avais
on n'est pas un examen si ces gens
étaient derrière moi m'ont pas compris
ce que c'est exactement ce que je trouve
que s'exprime vraiment bien c'est jean
marc parent jean marc parent lui le
sport quelqu'un qui s'exprime bien c'est
quelqu'un qui décroche pas qu'un qui
parle c'est à dire peu parlé par un 6
ans le monde rsa si dense a fait maintes
et maintes fois c'est tellement mon
idole depuis je me fais comparer souvent
j'en parle je me trouve grosse région
goran jean marc parent la petite baie
james et non non non mais jamais par
akpa ou email eli lilly parce que mon
public c'est de 7 à 77 ans les gens
aient un gap le fac et les enfants sont
les parents ils me disent leurs
commentaires au bâton puis souvent ça
revient je me fais penser à jean marc
parent parce que manger des chocs
peuvent durer quatre heures les
diffuseurs mbosso jusque sur 4 mois
parce que tu pendant une heure et deux
mois alors je fais du mot je parle de ce
qui s'est passé cette semaine je parle
de l'actualité je parle de n'importe
quoi j'improvise pas d'initier son genre
les on établit pour la tournée 2010 neuf
filiales avons chacun un tabouret pascal
lalle bédard et son genre bon dieu qui
ce petit achat mais c'est sa cinquième
fois comparé à lui c'est tellement naïve
c'est le monde quitte pas aux facs et
chine
c'est le monde qui se lèvent tous un peu
moins bag un sac hamas à faire savoir
qu'ils étaient non mais je demande
toujours si je parle beaucoup au public
jusqu'à mais non mais je corrige un
grand rôle dans ma vie je tout le temps
tourne et je vous prends ma famille
faction vaincue en dur et c'est bon mais
c'est nécessaire
j'ai eu un show la veille de l'adisq spi
le sas avait duré trois ans et demi 4
car oui parce que j'étais nerveuse puis
je leur en parler comment j'ai anticipé
ce réseau tsn
j'avais raconté gens m'ont fait avec
marie mai au premier
disque j'avais été nommé j'avais pas où
aller 30 ans quitte à gauche bague je
faisais ma mousse d'accord deux jours
avant le premier l'a dit sèchement
madame est tellement nice l1 mais oui
mais j music à se jeter comme des mamans
les cheveux comme se bouger c'est ça la
connaît pourtant la pression je la
connais vraiment à maupiti dans son
lancement
j'ai l'impression de silhouette on
c'est la rechange et décrypte
complètement aujourd'hui des deux
gérants sont jamais changé tout mais je
pressens cas a dit un petit peu jean
fauque oft répression qui est le c'était
comme l'image marc mepi l'oeil c'est
lourd à déconnecter as fuck off et simon
photo est ce que des melons d'eau
atteindra se fait coller pour les
gaspillages debout fait avec ses moyens
et steve wiebe poule mais ça ça parait
que ashley salhi pistes comme celles qui
vivent une deuxième vie complète c'est
un peu ce questionnement qui est chiant
à se poser c'est la question ça a cliqué
qui est un peu sur nos lèvres sur les
lèvres du québec au complet de force 6 à
s'émanciper à ce point le quand son mari
est décédé à quel point a été repris
après ses deux sauts de leur amour se
sait et je pense que c'était de l'amour
vraiment mais je pense que
il a modelé dans les cours de diction
parfaite à nyala commencer tellement
jeune personnellement star ac
était pas encourager à penser par
elle-même j'ai l'impression faisait dire
quoi dire confort eu une vie à trois des
quatre coins for humanity ça fait je
pense que on voit type scib mais système
laquelle le questionnement réel que sa
mère ait el pipita au québec c'est
difficile parce que quand tu poses un
questionnement comme ceux qui
s'attaquent 1
quilès à une statue québécoise le ti qui
tu peux pas attaquer rené angelil
peugeot sport et puis c'est pas de
l'attaqué mais des mâles en douce qui
veut oui mais de se poser la question
c'est un peu de remettre cinq ans d'août
puis je pense que on est prêt pour sa
part contre la question je trouve que à
se pose malgré tout on est juste à voir
comment céline aux leurs maintenant
c'est comme un rêve
ben tant mieux parce que elle où elle
est aujourd'hui pis après le rejet 90 5
mai
rodez c'est un palace toute l'histoire
de sa ville pendant des années les
trolls c'est une semaine même si la même
salle tout le temps imagine toute ta vie
ils y ont fait le stage pour rien et en
fait le stage en fonction pour ses
chevilles des foins
ses formes ouais mag mais je l'avais
rencontré ma première blonde rester sa
cousine ados - puis aller a fait son
show à traverser le lac saint jean puis
moi je te le blanc de l'époque puis on
est rentré on est rentré comme dans le
backstage plus ma blonde assise comme
placer le genre tiens il salue plus ont
vu plein moi je t'ai comme à côté mais
personne n'a introduit au cclat jeter
quand même plus les deux par les planes
et marie merci comme tourner la mode vue
georges tron demain sauf à me regarder
comme un peu creux la blonde en même
temps qu'elle avait le 12 août à tout
jouer au ballon et c'était pas que le
statut de star académie et à yuya
message assez fort mais on s'entend
comme tu disais pas parce que ce poste
par une grosse machine
la grosse machine la grosse machine que
ça marche si je travaillais forme ncl m6
et de toutes les années la mort parce
que c'est une des plus grosses dettes au
québec baisser
toute la ganja le quart des bears qui
toutes mes temps là voilà ce que ça
marche plus si on peut gagner si ce
n'est celle où je chante cinq ans non je
pense qu'un danger parce qu'ils étaient
trop anxieux j'avais juste d'un journal
à potins sadique de vue sur son art city
n'ont pas se séparer de louis j ça
disait qu'ils étaient trop anxieux bête
de partir loin peut-être céderait au
début que mouche commencé en fin de la
tournée toi je m'étais comme on dit à se
lancer dans ce marché
à côté une année assez des chances que
ce parvis quand j'avais 20 ans gérait
pot-au-feu
j'avais pas les outils nécessaires au
dessus d'étudier quelque chose troubles
anxieux ou quoi que ce soit
ah ouais j'ai de l'anxiété à côté puis
que ce fait pour ça que ce power mal à
moi j'étoufferai girard j rencontrer des
psychologues
ce qui a aussi pris des médicaments et
rien que j'ai pas faire d j'ai tout
essayé mais la meilleure thérapie je
pense et quand tu te situes tu acceptes
points
offrant une balle en or la france à ce
qu'un vrai
wafa sifac et les psys toute l'équipe
mais savons-nous tita sictom taxi parce
que je te comme dans le déni un peu
aussi point man et j'ai fait de garde
c'est ce que je suis j'ai grandi
j'évolue et puis je me suis par les
fautes mais je te dirai qu'il première
fois en avion le l'épisode suivant mon
et d'épopées ben loin la ferme ont une
fois de temps en temps quand c'est
vraiment trop trop intense pour herman
d'intenses la santé mentale fragile
c'est comme mode et à la longue
tout le monde se connaît oui mais oui
comme on habite dans la même bâtisse il
y avait il y avait un article sur une
danseuse qui allait les sumos par année
mon argent il faut 300 mètres pias
conacoh moyens la population 650 1000
par année et femmes au foyer sont contre
l'inde et les femmes la bouffe que jobs
appareil dépendant de la pataterie qui
dans le mur on ne pense qu'à 48 ans là
bas et j'ai fait l'egypte est une crise
oui j'ai pleuré d'un match était lancé
des enfants c'est ma grand mère je
t'aime quelqu'un qui fait des enfants
chanteurs qui guérissent et sans cesse
pourquoi et
elle était même si c'est dur et gmail
était pauvre mais le monde son compte
toi qui vont la bo puis je voulais
retourner le sujet les bâches vermont
mais la file a beau c'était pas une
grosse alger fait la plus petite salle
150 personnes mais qu'est ce qu'une
banque ou pas d'alcool pas que j'y verse
à mes musiciens c'était vraiment comme
en famille comme jeunes partisans tandis
que vu comment la ville dans leurs
belles salles de spectacles et
d'attaquer la montée lentement mon
challenge est partie de l'hôtel je
marche un kilomètre dans le spectacle
mais je me suis perdu faut que t'arrêtes
tour des parents dans le mur pour dire à
madame - la salle de spectacle et où on
organise lundi
j'aimerais bien me ce qui était drôle
c'est que la caisse enregistreuse élus
puis elle postule monstre de montchaude
re est en phase de jeu ce personnage
mais le jeu me ressemblait pas j'avais
j'ai eu tort que les cheveux foulon le
là dessus j'ai cheveux causé fhp com
c'est où la salle dotée la boucle à
petit avion que j'ai pris pour me rendre
au lycée dans 50 places ça les hélices à
bord de jean le monde à côté de nous il
ya des turbulences
ouais y'a vraiment bien est ce un homme
assez corpulent si on part de rien quand
neil bande à jean marc pillu sa job
c'est comme de me protéger le tournis
c'est correct ça va se retourner voir
mon pièce grâce à satiété pour venir se
régler j'écoutais c'est ça justement
j'écoute un podcast hier puis légué dit
qu'il y avait des problèmes d'anxiété
lui je trouvais ces deux de commencer à
faire déjouer à donjons dragons se
mettre dans un autre monde mais a tout
le temps de l'anxiété pluie dit c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut que tu
apprennes à gérer parce que ça s'en va
nulle part je peux pas tu peux pas
l'enlever pour juste que tu saches que
ceux-ci toi d'accepter que ça fait
partie toi pickeu savoir yves
dans mon salon
comment oracle c'est long avant que je
me rende compte qu'il est en train de
faire de l'anxiété comme on le sait
qu'au bout de la cinquième minute à
céline même là il sera moins bien un peu
mon genre ah bon ça y est je fonctionne
le tout assis pourquoi ne se réfléchit à
pourquoi cette action faisait foi se
trouve même pas pourquoi
oui parce qu'il m'aime pas de raison si
c'est juste commun
c'était un matin je me suis pris part
aux podcasts des fautes et anxieux
d'intention top par le stress a embarqué
ses marges en cette nuit j'ai rêvé que
fou qui voulait pas garder et jamais
rencontré fu chi de m'aguerrir de vie
mais devront se courait après dans des
escaliers pasqua puis fu kid c'est
probablement les deux personnes qu'on
s'est fait le plus demandé d'inviter
watrin pour chaque semaine je regarde
souvent jobs ce stage pendant trois ans
je pourrais jamais faire ce genre un
champ d'une touche de souffle habré mais
oui non c'est ça brasse investissement
qui travaillent fort en crise aussi dans
la maison qui tissent
ça prend ça prend des sites allant faire
fausse route c'est pas plus de place
pour les ramènerait gens tout le monde
commence que sa place en bleu j'irai me
semble que c'est parce que c'est joli
l'assemblée était trop d'avant-soirée de
la chambre pour rappel il était trop
d'avant sultan bin je devais choisir à
quelle rap et kiev ça ça existe
pendant longtemps on n'était pas en
forme et il est rapide était pas au
niveau qui était possible qu'est ce
qu'il faisait telltale du monde des
enfants qui sont ici c'est au tour de
rechange et kutesa xion je pense qu'il
connaît les jeunes qui commencent le
tipi ces malades c'est juste trop bon
tous et bon que n'importe quoi d'autre
mais pas de quoi des meilleurs sa femme
en question
mais pas de quoi des meilleures affaires
connaissez vous un peu la scène du rap
game ou si j'ai un bac là dedans c'est
là qu'est la wii connaît pas mais la wii
dans la louisiane
je comprends pas pourquoi la suisse a
poursuivi jean moi j'écoute la rue viger
liens et coûte sûrement sans germes
d'amont et quoi dire de quoi c'est sûr
qu'il écoute parce que on ne parle que
l'économie a de bonnes chances qu'ils
voient seul mais moi je t'ai sur un
podcast s'appelle qui s'appelle sports
30 ou est ce qu'on parle de sport d'or
puis de façon de 30 billets et la
question de mme aubry c'est ce qu'ils
t'ont rappeur qu'elle préférait que j'ai
dit larry qui dit oui puis moi ce que je
dis c'est que mettons les textes de son
album contrôle moi ça me rejoint plus
que les textes de l'armée dont piges et
là j'ai l'impression que la raison pour
laquelle ça paul v comme la salle v6 qui
était pas avec et justin étaient pas
avec la même équipe de prod les bêtes
sont moins en pointe mais moi c'est en
fait question de deux textes mais c'est
mon préféré
je trouve que là où des gens n'aient
rien à l'art c'est plus pop ouais
vraiment qu'elle a ri la missive
vraiment
guan 6 et l'expressionnisme narcisse et
de la poésie et bien que j'adore ce
vraiment pile là son prochain album et
trike et jazz puis j'ai vraiment de voir
que ça à faire parce que tu mets des
textes de même avec un pays qui a mis
fin au jazz sacoche là j'ai l'impression
sa groupe jaj maladie ce que j'avais
parlé avec lui de 4 secondes et just
puis en tant coulisses puisque vraiment
nerveuse puisse pas un sou il ya juste
fait jean et nerveuse de gizy easy way
est pas toi
non mais moi je pense imputant les
habitants comme un des âmes airlines et
quand un peu de fard ben oui c'est comme
montréal that ans et guitariste puis
honnêtement sur tout les guides corpo si
je peux dire maintenant je fais le show
le 31
wi-lan jeunes membres d'animaux guitare
et sochaux de rousseau jarny maurice
joss ça vient de lui loin s'essaye à une
expo mes chansons si c'était juste - ce
cd pour rendre le haut de leur amour
jamais seco que soit ce qu'il mérite
n'en s'est fallu immergeant mais pour
revenir à la route versus les huiles de
moteur
là au delà ces crissements des femmes
savent danser ses baisers clichés bobby
houle pauvre aide aux kings je vais
aller le beau t'es pas d'accord d'accord
je pense que personne plage il a eu
droit facile de refaire ce jeudi pour
que j'aurais copiant les accords de 2007
la série mi mai mais mimi même vitesse
pis ils et comment que les notes y
mettant le temps s'écoulait depuis
l'automne c'est dans la garde parce que
j'ose la même vitesse même groupe
betty en vidéo pop tout le monde se
tient toute copie le jeu des propos tim
est en écoute soumis dans le tarn et on
t'écoute l'étonnant 92 le tout est une
pomme à 92 sont toutes pareilles 10,1
2003 aussi une sifakis ses collègues
c'est normal effectivement je pense que
le succès de la hausse et aussi parce
que yi vraiment trendy en italie dans
les trucs son hôte lopy gauthier qui
mais c'est bien correct vraiment correct
mais j'ai rien contre ce médecin
sarrazin gobain être avertis aussi bien
moi mais ça laisse matic un christ
serait pas sans succès ou si vraiment il
sans ciller
je peux comparer messi je pense qu'ils
étaient plus plus naturellement quelques
sympathiques rockets qui rien à fort que
la rime et on mais moi c'est quand ok
les membres enfin parce que jamais chez
moi là oui je trouve fort king show je
sais pas pourquoi ça doit être ses
textes sa droite s'amuse avec succès je
trouve qu'ils beau mais mes jambes tout
mais pourquoi on fait ça pour quoi
la comparaison est trop évidente qu'on
peut souhaiter mais en tout cas mais je
compte en savoir que je peux seul le
monde manque un peu comme moi tu étais
un peu plus sur les maux de tête
pitch du pot clouds et aix et la bombe
ont aussi laissé cause qui fait osciller
mais je trouve que ouais ok ça au plus
d'émotions trouve sapin mnm blanc je
n'en étais pas exactement
si vraiment ce que madame danois mnm
québec où il ya un apport concédé mais
même si kiel c'est la partie avec le
québécois j'ai dit blanc après jean
[Rires]
ouest un peu c'est un peu comme un
djezzy nom et vos fassassi vous allez
rire montage c'est sûr mais nous avons
déjà livré mais moi je laisse capable
d'aider des bonbons la richesse comme un
bonbon mnm blanc s'il n'y a pas de
couleur
on n'est plus des jantes texte et
c'était tout non mais vous comprenez ce
que je faisais je trouve qu'il fait
underground gentils sont exactement
qu'est blanc bardella bien encore ouais
ouais mais là oui ce qui marche à
tabarnak ce sont des gens tout le monde
sur le beagle puis enfin moi même très
bonnes c'est qu'il ya utiliser et
utiliser un peu en fait
c'est lahoud avec son jack est tout le
monde vu leur d'action jacket
c'est chris rudge jaquette officielle
montréal mes ennemis jawad de fox in
sense avec la presse à ses participants
de ce matériau parce que moi je me suis
acheté un jacket j'ai enfilé un jean
blanc bleu rouge en vraiment ça fait 80
la blonde indien on dirait que tu
t'habilles comme lahoud
tabarnak la mode mais c'est vrai mais je
vois beaucoup de monde avec intrakat
officiel vraiment vraiment beaucoup
n'ont pas répété des fois le succès
vient où la terre - le style go wi fait
du rap mais je dise il ya un succès un
homme dans leur âme mais encore plus
énorme ayotte
il faut l'accepter mais je pense que
deux
on comprend des questions comment ces
composants ont fini avant de terminer le
podcast avec des questions du public
maintenant le speech on sait que oui je
sais c'est quoi je m'étais inscrit
j'aurai mon mot de passe mais s'inscrit
comme 2-1 le monde la demande et puis au
début au déclassement posture parce que
je lève mon chapeau parce que ces gens
qu'il faut je donne ce contenu exclusif
nous autres on va faire des pas de casse
juste les deux concours spi c'est avant
de faire le premier pas de casse on
avait fait une pratique qu'on veut c'est
juste nous deux pour la lecture en fête
qui est vraiment bon et intéressant
il faut voir pas pour se flatter j'ai
regardé vos podcasts
il ya beaucoup de postes de podcasts ou
j'avance or le salaire intéressant je
laisse rouler votre podcast c'est vrai
que c'est pas de longueur pillet merci
jean vous mettez le monde à l'image et
dirigé des entrevues avec des interviews
que ce sera un travail plus bombée quoi
merci merci et chapeau à la question si
d'alexandra duchaine sur peyton
si tu devais choisir entre continuer à
créer de la musique ou continue à créer
du contenu web lequel du frais admettons
qu'on dit tu peux continuer à faire des
albums
sauf que sur les deux côtés et vive la
création de contenus livrés ou en sur
web fait qu'il ait cette bande
développent ou le contrat
je pense que je pensais de créer de la
musique ouais est-ce que tu définis plus
le sait plus avec sandra tu sais moi à
chaque mets toi toi mais tu en es ce que
tu as tendance à ce que l'on va faire
notre trou après puis saveurs de boucler
la boucle sur ce podcast ci qu'on a
commencé comme ça est ce que tu décris
plus comme auteur compositeur interprète
ou une créateurs de contenu c'est pas la
première fois qu'on me pose cette
question je suis content toujours la
même chose je me qualifie de ni l'un ni
l'autre je me qualifie de roxane bruno
c'est tellement beau j'espérais que cela
monte parce que lisicki apaiser les
boîtes bon exemple de des boîtes qui
disparaissent tellement merci mamie
smaer blanc comme un messmer est ce que
vous avez une question peut-être comment
avoir de éventuellement mais on va
choisir celles qu'on juge sénat qui le
personnage d'un gang par cas mais
commence à poser quelques questions 8000
pitchouns pour l'instant combien de
nantes à 14 ans mais non mais ouvrez
genre quatorze personnes qui qui paye à
chaque mois pour entendre père georges
canguilhem qui veulent exporter fait
chaud c'est incroyable show ce qui est
vrai c'est que vous avez jamais pas à
saler sur twitch non non non c'est là
bas parce que loeb reste chez nous
[Musique]
parce que vous avez toute la guerre pour
la forme alors mes gars dont on n'est
pas sans rappeler celle des enfants puis
on apprend en faisant sa chique il y en
a beaucoup qui font leur pas de cas ils
réussissent a twistick sur pétuaud n'y
ont accès à le vocal à 20 ou après le ca
devient con exclusif au playstation on
donne des trucs en avance on donne les
trucs du genre en avance on fait des
podcasts les deux ensembles qui pour un
peu plus et peut poser des questions
vous savez le second fait toujours plus
belles lettres permettant d'avoir un
char à foin ou donnons générer les
enfants même si l'enfant plus
honorifique que six autres est vraiment
en pis c'est pourquoi feint-on
archambault merci beaucoup d'avoir jeté
des oeufs devant aller de monde fait
attention aux reptiles et surtout
[Musique]